[Applause]
you want to drive your enemies nuts have
a lot more fun than they are remember I
said would I be a little bit wild and
would have a lot of fun
they'd say he's not acting presidential
and I'd say well it's a lot easier to
act presidential than to do what I do
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen of the state of
Florida thank you very much for being
here
you are tremendous people and I will
leave now because I am boring you to
death
thank you can any president in history
except for possibly Abe Lincoln with the
big head I don't know
Abe Lincoln with the big hat
could you imagine Abe and Trump in a
debate check out mr. big head over here
mr. big hat what's he hiding under there
mr. big hat and other smaller hats all
right so what's all this fun causing the
people not having fun are getting sick
of you of Trump of themselves for
example since Trump got elected there's
been a jump in patients suffering from
what scientists call Trump anxiety
disorder or tad tad isn't everything bad
named tad I mean do you know a good tad
by the way that was a tadpole
went a long way for that joke long way
wasted a lot of time for that one all
right
according to CBC News a symptom of tad
as a feeling as if the world is ending
wonder who's spreading that Donald Trump
and his erratic behavior could be
leading the United States towards World
War three violating millions of people
if this border wall happens it will be
an unprecedented environmental
catastrophe we can't begin to normalize
this this is dangerous this is childish
this is unpresidential this is it's the
end of the presidential race and it
feels like the end of the world of
course now it's easy to mock this
suffering but I'm not when you see
what's coming out of the quivering
Cronkite's you can't blame gentler Souls
for falling ill there's a whole industry
selling us fear and they're calling it
facts
that's another symptom that the fear
spreads faster than a cold sore from
Bill Clinton fear sells
fear sells yourself so now the media has
replaced climate change with Trump
change as an apocalyptic
wish-fulfillment
everything bad in this world is Trump's
fault pick any bad news and you can
trace it back to him even stuff that
happened before he was born
World War one Trump's false World War to
Trump's fault synchronized swimming
Trump's fault the problem things just
keep getting better we're doing pretty
good with North Korea in the Middle East
GDP is going up and unemployment keeps
dropping consumer confidence is higher
than Obama's mom jeans
we have peace and prosperity yet the
other networks seem C doomsday every day
is doomsday and there's the problem if
every day is doomsday how do you know
what the real doomsday is what we need
is a super-duper doomsday what if
everything you knew about doomsday was
wrong get ready for super duper doomsday
where it's really really the end of the
world for sure no lie it's going to
happen we swear so buckle up you're
going to die and so is everyone else it
all starts when President Trump severely
slices a tee shot while golfing at
mar-a-lago the ball careens off into
space
striking a nearby asteroid which then
crashes into the moon splitting it into
thousands of pieces moon fragments smash
earth TV satellites causing them to only
broadcast the view 24 hours a day
this causes the world IQ to plummet
dramatically except for Chris Cuomo he
actually becomes smarter let's get after
it
human idiots begin chasing each other in
stores with alligators causing Dana
Perino to swear like a sailor turtles
quickly become the dominant species and
start eating everything causing them to
grow at an exponential rate the UN
responds by making another movie about
ABBA that sucks so bad it causes the Sun
to hurl itself into Jupiter causing all
of our blenders to make nothing but the
worst kind of virgin daiquiris meanwhile
the giant turtles have begun to devour
entire cities causing Don Lemon to speak
in reverse English don't believe what
you see with her own ears
within hours only a few hundred humans
remain as the final survivors mount a
last stand by electing Adam Levine as
their leader he tries to make peace by
singing
[Music]
upon hearing this the earth itself
implodes destroying everything ever
created except a doomsday bunker fold my
pillows thus completing super duper
doomsday
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so the ugly truth as the media
Hollywood academia deplore Trump they
wouldn't exist without him seriously if
Trump were to disappear what would they
be doing so if you think these people
are sick from Trump anxiety just imagine
their Trump withdrawal talk about a
doomsday fact is you can't go back after
Donald Donald T's introduce something
into politics that we haven't seen in
quite a while
it's energy media anxiety isn't from the
apocalypse it's from trying to keep up
it's the first time in eight years
they've had to they see these weird damp
circles underneath their arms and they
go what the hell is that doctor it's
sweat something you didn't see when you
were reporting about Obama so what about
us things are going pretty good
which means it's time for tough love
with Greg Gutfeld
welcome to tough love with Greg Gutfeld
look I'm not crazy about CNN or Jim
Acosta
he's like a tube of Brylcreem that
learned to pout but the but the jeering
at the rallies it's really not a good
look and I mean it it's like when I
drink too much I think that I look great
but in reality I shouldn't be in the
park wearing nothing but Crocs they
never believe me when I say I'm walking
a dog so when I see all the yelling at
Acosta I do get the anger the jeering is
born from a cynicism about a press that
under Obama had their spines removed to
make it easier to bend over and now it's
clean it's clean now that trumps here
you see the media working overtime and
it's the contrast that bugs you and me
but when you're winning and you are you
don't need to scream in fact I think
that's piling on so my suggestion stop
and instead do what my mom always said
kill him with kindness it wasn't a
machete I can never tell with mom it was
either kindness or a machete with her
there was no middle ground but let's
stick with kindness you got to be
appreciative and take the high road it'd
be nicer you'll look better and it will
drive the media even more nuts and
they'll be so confused they'll probably
think it's the end of the world again
[Applause]
let's welcome tonight's guest that's not
a truck backing up we're just bleeping
her filthy language my co-host on the
5:00 and anchor of the daily briefing or
bleeping Dana Perino
besides the TV dinner she's my favorite
Swanson the original Vampire Slayer the
legendary Buffy herself actress Kristy
Swanson one of the best intro sever her
keyboard only has one letter which is
why she's always D pressing master of
your reporter cat tip that's too good
and his baseball cap gets altitude
sickness
former WWE Superstar of my massive
sidekick Tyrus
[Applause]
all right Dana I can't believe I have to
say this but try to keep it clean we
have some children here in the audience
what do you what do you make I guess the
idea that this conflict between the
media and the administration and who
should take the high road should we take
the high road do I remember what Jed
intended I said on the five which kind
of struck me we have like when I lecture
people we have the luxury of a show so
we can talk about we can talk about all
the all the stuff that the audience
media driving us crazy like we have an
outlet for it but the people at the
rallies don't so when they see CNN they
go you because that's their outlet so am
I wrong no I don't think that that's
wrong but I think that your advice is
actually good the tough love right
because I do think not to get technical
on the polls yeah you know he's bleeding
women the approval ratings are
plummeting for him with women yeah and
it's not about the economy they know the
economy is good
it's not about Russia they don't really
care about Russia it's his temperament
and so I think that that is just not
helping isn't it's not necessary I think
at the reporters they don't even
actually need to be in the room yeah
they could be outside yes and you're
just gonna see it on that you have one
TV camera one camera like Jim Acosta
doesn't need to be in there outside he's
becoming part of the story yeah it's not
necessary but if they're outside the
story will be reporters kept outside
Trump's fault
Christie welcome to the show so much
good news in the economy is that what's
driving the media kind of nuts is that
they can't figure out what to say about
them they just want to put him down at
any chance that they have I mean they
just want to just destroy him like your
video that we just saw it's just it's
terrible it's bad mm-hmm and they need
to stop their aging themselves are they
aging is they look like you're getting
gray or white yeah yeah look at I mean
they just look so angry and awful and
you know they need to lighten up yeah
changes them yeah I've noticed Anderson
Cooper's hair is totally white
and Stelter bald I mean these are
they're obviously having an effect cat
what give me some of your deep analysis
on what's going on the current political
climate how you feel are you angry
are you nervous perturbed I'm angry and
nervous and perturbed it's usually about
other stuff like about when I get food
later what if I order the wrong thing
and I don't like it and I wish I got
another thing right or what if when I'm
walking down the street someone sneezes
on me and then I get a cold again or
what if I hang out with someone who
seems to be healthy but they're actually
harboring the cold virus and I wound up
getting sick from them because they're
still contagious I'm seeing a trend here
a lot of things definitely to worry
about I don't worry so much I mean the
amount of anxiety that some people have
about President Trump only one person
should have that kind of anxiety about
the president and that's the president
[Applause]
making important decisions but I think
actually I get a little more nervous
about my food order than he does he
seems like he kind of just is pretty
chill about being the president no I
think you know what i-i've had talked
about this before to him it's just
another kind of a big project and anyway
he talks about it like it's a job he
will share the details of this job to
you that no president ever would like
all the the stuff he has to deal with
tyrus but I'm glad you made it you
almost didn't make it tonight yeah I
made it
yeah he was circling he was circling for
four hours above this studio yep yeah it
was great if I if I could piggyback on
Dana Perino for a second shut up I think
he's got a great core base she could do
it maybe not for a long time these three
steps three stuff will get out but her
point was spot on the Acosta thing I
because of my background in wrestling
mm-hm and and president Trump has a long
historic history with wrestling and this
is Vince McMahon one
right and of Kostas he Acosta likes the
chanting he likes that stuff because
you're exactly right
why is he not on the outside reporters
used to do that but you can't get those
reactions in those ratings he even so
they can see him stands up higher than
the crowd and stands over them that's
true hey I'm here I'm here and then they
get going they start doing the wrestling
chants you suck or whatever it is and he
eats it up and he acts that and strut
but he literally if he got down and
walked away to do his report it would be
over yeah he's doing it for the
attention for the same reason that he
despises President Trump who seeks
attention they do the same thing it's
because they are involved in a war yeah
I mean the media and specifically most
of the seems like cNN has become the
front-runner in this one-on-one dogfight
with with the president and they're
willing to go anywhere to go after him
and then but they want to hold
themselves in a higher court but there
are the same yeah and Trump he's he's
the babyface right now so the crowds
gonna cheer him they're gonna boo you so
just yeah yeah and you know it is it is
a mismatch because he's a street fight
this is who he is it's that I didn't win
this fight yeah yeah it was even how to
be a good heel like it cost me what if
some like a shut up lady or sure how'd
you get here you can't afford it like
start heckling the crowd back Acosta
like you be a bad guy I'm doing a report
on you sir and your extramarital you
know
[Applause]
I gave earlier you can't if you can't
beat them join them
Yeah right and like laughs yeah just
laughs maybe it'll be better yeah I just
hope that I hope that like some I just
would like it to just it does mob people
looking like a mob doesn't appeal to me
whether in a v-shape form because I'm
really a good person at heart
no I'm not I'm a terrible person
[Applause]